Louisa Ewanitis was just 24 years old, yet her untimely death in 2011 received little more than a brief mention in a local newspaper. Found in a creek, police quickly dismissed any suspicion, despite her being a strong swimmer. This is the story behind Troubled Waters, the latest original podcast from Casefile Presents. Led by seasoned private investigator Julia Robson, the podcast uncovers a gripping narrative full of intrigue. From an international kidnapping and a daring escape, this is like no story you've ever heard before. The entire Troubled Waters series is available now.
路易莎·埃瓦尼蒂斯年仅24岁，然而她2011年那场不合时宜的死亡，在当地报纸上仅得到了简短的提及。她被发现死于一条小溪中，尽管她是一名游泳健将，警方还是很快排除了任何疑点。这就是《困水》（Troubled Waters）背后的故事，这是Casefile Presents推出的最新原创播客。该播客由经验丰富的私家侦探朱莉娅·罗布森主持，揭开了一个充满阴谋的扣人心弦的故事。从国际绑架到大胆逃脱，这就像你从未听过的任何故事。整个《困水》系列现已上线。
Listen to all 10 episodes of Troubled Waters wherever you get your podcasts. Stay tuned to the end of today's episode to hear the trailer. Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. Married couple Stephen and Carol Baxter lived on Mersey Island along England's East Coast. Both were aged in their 60s and Carol suffered from an autoimmune disease that was slowly stripping away her ability to fully function. As a result, the couple's loved ones regularly
请在您获取播客的任何地方收听《困水》的所有10集内容。请收听今天这一集的结尾以获取预告片。我们的剧集涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看您应用程序或我们网站上本集的节目说明。斯蒂芬·巴克斯特和卡罗尔·巴克斯特夫妇住在英国东海岸的默西岛上。两人都已60多岁，卡罗尔患有一种自身免疫性疾病，这种疾病正在慢慢剥夺她完全正常生活的能力。因此，这对夫妇的亲人经常
checked in on them via calls, messages and emails. When the Baxter's didn't respond to any of their incoming communications throughout Saturday April 8 2023 and the morning of Sunday April 9, concerns for their welfare grew. When there was still no word from them by midday, the couple's 22-year-old daughter Ellie Baxter went over to pay them a visit. Ellie, who was four months pregnant, arrived at her parents' two-story house in West Mersey with her partner Marcus. her parents' two-story house in West Mersey with her partner Marcus. The pair immediately sensed something was wrong. The first thing Stephen Baxter did every morning was open his window blinds, but the blinds were still closed and the lights were on inside. Ellie knocked on the front door, but there was no answer. She headed around to the other side of the house to try
通过电话、短信和电子邮件查看他们的情况。当巴克斯特夫妇在2023年4月8日星期六和4月9日星期日上午对所有收到的通讯都没有回应时，人们对他们安危的担忧加剧了。到了中午仍然没有他们的消息，这对夫妇22岁的女儿艾莉·巴克斯特便去探望他们。怀有四个月身孕的艾莉与她的伴侣马库斯一起来到了她父母位于西默西的两层住宅。两人立刻感觉到不对劲。斯蒂芬·巴克斯特每天早上做的第一件事就是拉开窗帘，但窗帘仍然关着，屋里的灯也亮着。艾莉敲了敲前门，但没有人应答。她绕到房子的另一侧去尝试
the back door. Peering through the windows of the conservatory, Ellie saw her parents sitting bolt upright in their favourite recliner chairs. They were unresponsive, their hands had turned blue, and liquid was trickling out of Carol's mouth. A spare key wasn't in its usual place, so Ellie and Marcus desperately tried to break in. A neighbour overheard the couple violently banging against the conservatory's door while Ellie frantically yelled, they're not moving. 18 years earlier, in 2005, Carol Baxter was diagnosed with Hashimoto's disease. The autoimmune disorder affects the thyroid gland at the base of the neck, which is responsible for regulating many functions in the body. For individuals with the condition, their immune system cells wrongly attack the
后门。透过温室的窗户往里看，艾莉看到她的父母笔直地坐在他们最喜欢的躺椅上。他们没有反应，双手已经发青，卡罗尔的嘴里流出了液体。备用钥匙不在平时放的地方，所以艾莉和马库斯拼命试图破门而入。一位邻居听到这对夫妇猛烈地撞击温室的门，同时艾莉疯狂地尖叫着：“他们不动了。”18年前，即2005年，卡罗尔·巴克斯特被诊断出患有桥本氏病。这种自身免疫性疾病会影响颈部底部的甲状腺，而甲状腺负责调节体内的许多功能。对于患有这种疾病的人来说，他们的免疫系统细胞会错误地攻击
thyroid's hormone-producing cells, resulting in a decline in hormone production. The disease progresses slowly over years, resulting in varied symptoms from brittle nails, hair loss and swelling, to fatigue, muscle pain, and a decline in cognitive function. In 2021, a close family friend who had observed Carol's ongoing health struggles began researching ways to help her. They eventually found a renowned endocrinologist named Dr Andrea Bowden, who specialised in the diagnosis and treatment of hormone-related diseases and conditions. in the diagnosis and treatment of hormone-related diseases and conditions. Although Dr. Bodum was based overseas in the US state of Florida, she was able to communicate with Carol online. Carol sent her videos and emails explaining her illness and was given medical advice in
甲状腺的激素分泌细胞，导致激素分泌减少。这种疾病多年来缓慢进展，导致各种症状，从指甲变脆、脱发和肿胀，到疲劳、肌肉疼痛和认知功能下降。2021年，一位一直观察卡罗尔健康状况挣扎的亲密家庭朋友开始研究帮助她的方法。他们最终找到了一位名叫安德里亚·鲍登博士的著名内分泌学家，她专门从事激素相关疾病和病症的诊断和治疗。尽管鲍登博士身处海外的美国佛罗里达州，但她能够在线与卡罗尔交流。卡罗尔给她发送了视频和电子邮件解释她的病情，并得到了医疗建议作为
return. Dr. Bodum soon introduced Carol to another patient of hers named Cheryl Harring, believing the two women would benefit from sharing their experiences. Over email, Carol and Cheryl relayed their health fears, aired their grievances, and helped ease one another's anxieties. A close friendship was quickly established, with the pair bonding over more than just their shared medical condition. Cheryl had a sister named Jenny Trencher who was a theatre producer in London.
回报。鲍登博士很快将卡罗尔介绍给了她的另一位病人谢丽尔·哈林，认为这两位女性通过分享她们的经历会受益匪浅。通过电子邮件，卡罗尔和谢丽尔交流了她们对健康的恐惧，倾诉了她们的委屈，并帮助缓解了彼此的焦虑。一段亲密的友谊很快建立起来，两人不仅因为共同的疾病而结缘。谢丽尔有一个名叫珍妮·特伦彻的妹妹，她是伦敦的一名戏剧制作人。
This was a big deal to Carol as her daughter Ellie was an aspiring singer. She put Ellie in touch with the Jenny, who encouraged her to send through some vocal samples in case she could help her get a contract or professional lessons. In a message to Ellie, Jenny wrote, I was talking to your lovely mum last week and we had a nice chat on a day she was feeling well. Today would it be possible to have recordings sent? They don't need to be perfect. sent. They don't need to be perfect." Ellie appreciated the opportunity and recorded herself singing a song requested by Jenny, I'd Do Anything, from the musical Oliver. In time, Carol Baxter was introduced to two other patients of Dr. Andrea Bowden who had Hashimoto's disease, Linda Edwards and Marni Pantry. Along with Carol and Cheryl,
这对卡罗尔来说是一件大事，因为她的女儿艾莉是一位有抱负的歌手。她让艾莉与珍妮取得了联系，珍妮鼓励她寄去一些声乐样本，看看能否帮她获得合同或专业课程。在给艾莉的一条信息中，珍妮写道：“我上周和你可爱的妈妈谈过，在她感觉良好的一天，我们聊得很开心。今天能把录音发过来吗？它们不需要完美。”艾莉很感激这个机会，并录下了自己演唱珍妮要求的歌曲——音乐剧《奥利弗》中的《我愿意做任何事》（I'd Do Anything）。后来，卡罗尔·巴克斯特被介绍给了安德里亚·鲍登博士的其他两位患有桥本氏病的病人：琳达·爱德华兹和玛妮·潘特里。连同卡罗尔和谢丽尔，
the four women formed a small support group on instant messaging application WhatsApp. Dr. Bowden had a series of strict rules for how the women should treat and manage their conditions. She favoured herbal remedies and nutritional supplements over modern medicine, recommending her patients drink natural tonics like lemon in boiling water and smoothies with kale and flax seed. She also advised them to avoid anything that could be over-exerting. While Cheryl, Linda and Marnie were sticklers for the rules. Carol divulged to the group that she was doing housework against Dr. Bowden's advice. Cheryl responded, You are completely ignoring the rules. No washing, no dishwashing. Don't even bother making
这四位女性在即时通讯应用程序WhatsApp上组成了一个小型支持小组。鲍登博士对这些女性应该如何治疗和管理她们的病情有一套严格的规定。她偏爱草药疗法和营养补充剂，而不是现代医学，建议她的病人喝天然补品，如沸水加柠檬，以及羽衣甘蓝和亚麻籽奶昔。她还建议她们避免任何可能过度劳累的事情。虽然谢丽尔、琳达和玛妮是规则的死忠拥护者，但卡罗尔向小组透露，她违背了鲍登博士的建议在做家务。谢丽尔回应道：“你完全无视了规则。不准洗衣服，不准洗碗。甚至不要费心去为它找
excuses for it. I had you down for a smart lady. I really did. Carol, get a grip please. Play by the rules and stop trying to do things. You are seriously ill." At one stage, Carol also confided in her support group that Dr Andrea Bowden's more holistic approach to treating her thyroid condition clashed with the advice given by her general practitioner. In contrast to Dr Bowden's recommendations, Carol's GP prescribed her pharmaceutical drugs that substituted her missing thyroid hormones and had her blood tested annually to keep track of things. When Carol told her GP about the herbs, vitamins, remedies and routines
借口。我一直认为你是一位聪明的女士。我真的这么认为。卡罗尔，请振作起来。遵守规则，停止尝试做这些事情。你病得很重。”有一次，卡罗尔还向她的支持小组吐露，安德里亚·鲍登博士治疗她甲状腺疾病的更全面的方法与她的全科医生给出的建议相冲突。与鲍登博士的建议相反，卡罗尔的全科医生给她开了药物，以替代她缺失的甲状腺激素，并让她每年进行血液检查以跟踪情况。当卡罗尔告诉她的全科医生关于鲍登博士建议的草药、维生素、疗法和日常安排时，
advised by Dr. Bowden, he was incredulous. He had never come across that type of treatment for Hashimoto's disease and felt it was a load of rubbish. He was surprised that an expert in endocrinology would offer health advice that had no scientific merit. When Carol told her support group this, they called GPs fuckwits and stood firmly behind the care provided by Dr Andrea Boden. In a message to Carol, Marnie Pantry wrote, Honestly Carol, I have my life back. Listen to Andrea. Stop fighting it. I do not know what you are going through, only that we are very similar and you were stuck in the same phase I was eight months ago. I was ill and one day I finally listened.
他感到难以置信。他从未见过那种治疗桥本氏病的方法，并认为那是一堆垃圾。他很惊讶一位内分泌学专家会提供没有任何科学依据的健康建议。当卡罗尔告诉她的支持小组这件事时，她们称全科医生为“混蛋”，并坚定地支持安德里亚·鲍登博士提供的护理。在给卡罗尔的一条信息中，玛妮·潘特里写道：“老实说，卡罗尔，我找回了我的生活。听安德里亚的。别再反抗了。我不知道你正在经历什么，只知道我们非常相似，你正处于我八个月前所处的同一个阶段。我当时病得很重，有一天我终于听了话。
Use my experience and whatever Andrea says. Stick to the rules, Carol." Carol valued the input of those in her position and found herself drifting away from her GP and relying more on Dr Andrea Bowden. Over time, Carol opened up to Dr Bowden about her life at home, including her family and work. Her husband and daughter also emailed the doctor with occasional updates about how Carol was coping. As Dr. Bowden learnt more about the Baxter's, she was able to provide more personalised advice on how to minimise stress in the household by addressing specific problems they had with each other and the people around them. She told Carol that seeing family members, quote, released too many chemicals in the adrenal gland and advised, keep contact less regular.
利用我的经验和安德里亚说的任何话。遵守规则，卡罗尔。”卡罗尔重视那些处于她同样处境的人的意见，发现自己逐渐疏远了全科医生，转而更多地依赖安德里亚·鲍登博士。随着时间的推移，卡罗尔向鲍登博士敞开心扉，谈论了她的家庭生活，包括她的家人和工作。她的丈夫和女儿也偶尔给医生发电子邮件，更新卡罗尔的康复情况。随着鲍登博士对巴克斯特一家了解得越多，她就越能提供更个性化的建议，通过解决他们彼此之间以及与周围人之间存在的具体问题，来最大限度地减少家庭压力。她告诉卡罗尔，见到家人会“释放肾上腺中过多的化学物质”，并建议：“减少接触频率。
Why not take your family out weekly one at a time? You can't avoid seeing your family, but you have a serious illness and you need to be sensible. Moderate seeing family. It's that simple. Do not do anything that produces too much cortisol, which is one way to the grave. It's that simple. Despite her illness, Carol maintained a zest for life and persevered as best as she could by taking regular walks and visiting the gym. She continued to drink the health tonics recommended by Dr. Bowden, even when they tasted foul. Still, her overall wellness continued to deteriorate. She lost weight, struggled with fatigue, and her memory started getting foggy. On Tuesday February 8, 2022, Carol was hospitalized after complaining of abdominal pain.
为什么不每周带你的家人出去一次，一次只带一个人呢？你无法避免见到你的家人，但你患有严重的疾病，你需要理智一点。适度见家人。就这么简单。不要做任何会产生过多皮质醇的事情，那是一条通往坟墓的路。就这么简单。”尽管患病，卡罗尔仍保持着对生活的热情，并尽其所能通过定期散步和去健身房来坚持下去。她继续喝鲍登博士推荐的健康补品，即使它们味道很糟糕。尽管如此，她的整体健康状况仍在持续恶化。她体重下降，饱受疲劳困扰，记忆力也开始变得模糊。2022年2月8日星期二，卡罗尔因腹痛被送往医院。
To everyone's horror, X-rays revealed a 17mm metal nail was lodged in her colon. Carol had no idea how it got there. By 2023, Carol's confusion had worsened and she became wracked with tremors. Her symptoms were extreme for Hashimoto's disease and more in line with a dementia patient or someone who had suffered a stroke. Carol was referred to several specialists, but her unusual symptoms left them puzzled. It was hard for Carol's loved ones to see her suffer. One day, her daughter Ellie found her ironing a shirt on the kitchen cooktop while foam spilled out from the overloaded dishwasher nearby. Carol had no idea what she was doing. Ellie had never seen her mother in such a state and it brought her to tears.
令所有人惊恐的是，X光检查显示她的结肠里嵌着一颗17毫米的金属钉。卡罗尔根本不知道它是怎么进去的。到了2023年，卡罗尔的困惑加剧，并开始遭受震颤。她的症状对于桥本氏病来说太极端了，更像是痴呆症患者或中风患者的症状。卡罗尔被转诊给几位专家，但她不寻常的症状让他们感到困惑。看到她受苦，卡罗尔的亲人们很难过。有一天，她的女儿艾莉发现她在厨房灶台上熨烫衬衫，而旁边超负荷的洗碗机里溢出了泡沫。卡罗尔根本不知道自己在做什么。艾莉从未见过母亲处于这种状态，这让她泪流满面。
Stephen Baxter did the best he could to help his wife but he too felt helpless. Her decline was taking its toll on him too. Carol made plans to meet with Cheryl Harring from her support group in person for the first time. Stephen drove her over three hours away to a luxury hotel in the village of Warwickshire for the meeting, but Cheryl wasn't there. Stephen texted his daughter Ellie with an update saying, No sign of that Cheryl, not even answering mum's texts. Ellie replied, What is it with these women? Hopefully Cheryl is okay and turns up. Stephen wrote back, Not bothered, messing Carol about too much. Complete radio silence is poor. I will update you tomorrow.
斯蒂芬·巴克斯特尽其所能帮助他的妻子，但他自己也感到无助。她的衰退也对他造成了影响。卡罗尔计划第一次亲自与支持小组的谢丽尔·哈林见面。斯蒂芬开车带她去了三个多小时路程外沃里克郡村庄的一家豪华酒店参加会议，但谢丽尔并没有出现。斯蒂芬给女儿艾莉发了一条更新信息说：“没看到那个谢丽尔，甚至不回妈妈的短信。”艾莉回复道：“这些女人是怎么回事？希望谢丽尔没事并能出现。”斯蒂芬回信说：“不在乎了，把卡罗尔折腾得够呛。完全的无线电静默太糟糕了。我明天再告诉你。”
Much to Carol's disappointment, Cheryl never turned up, explaining later that she had a medical emergency. Despite continuing to follow Dr. Bowden's instructions, Carole's condition continued to worsen. Before she could seriously question whether the holistic approach was right for her, Dr. Bowden put Carole in contact with another doctor named Alan Mandel. Dr. Mandel supported Dr. Bowden's professional opinion and offered Carole his own guidance. He
令卡罗尔非常失望的是，谢丽尔从未出现，后来解释说她遇到了医疗紧急情况。尽管继续遵循鲍登博士的指示，卡罗尔的病情仍在持续恶化。在她能认真质疑这种整体疗法是否适合她之前，鲍登博士让卡罗尔联系了另一位名叫艾伦·曼德尔的医生。曼德尔博士支持鲍登博士的专业意见，并向卡罗尔提供了他自己的指导。他
provided the recipe of a health drink he asserted would cleanse Carole's liver. He suggested that Stephen Baxter drink it too for his own benefit, but warned that the drink wouldn't taste nice and would cause drowsiness. On Wednesday, April 5, 2023, Dr Andrea Bowden emailed Stephen Baxter to express her concern about Carole's deteriorating condition. She wrote, condition. She wrote, Carol has to accept I am worried something may happen, not just to her, any of you. Marnie's husband nearly got stabbed because she left knives out. If anything happens to anyone, it would be on you, her nearest. It would be, why have you let her, Steve? Sorry Steve, but I fear the worst now. You need protecting from what
提供了一种他声称可以净化卡罗尔肝脏的健康饮料配方。他建议斯蒂芬·巴克斯特也喝这种饮料以对自己有好处，但警告说这种饮料味道不好，会导致嗜睡。2023年4月5日星期三，安德里亚·鲍登博士给斯蒂芬·巴克斯特发电子邮件，表达了她对卡罗尔病情恶化的担忧。她写道：“卡罗尔必须接受，我很担心可能会发生什么，不仅仅是对她，对你们任何人都一样。玛妮的丈夫差点被捅伤，因为她把刀放在外面。如果任何人发生了什么事，那都是你的责任，你是她最亲近的人。到时候会是，‘史蒂夫，你为什么让她这样？’抱歉史蒂夫，但我现在担心最坏的情况。你需要保护自己免受
can happen unless you destroy this illness once and for all. Please let me help. Read this email out to her. Carol cannot rationalise." It was four days later on on Sunday April 9, that Ellie Baxter arrived at her parents' home to find them both unresponsive in their separate reclining chairs. A neighbour who overheard the commotion rushed over with a claw hammer that Ellie's partner Marcus used to smash their way inside. Carol and Stephen were both cold to the touch. Ellie began stroking her mother's hair, pleading with her to wake up. An ambulance rushed to the scene, but it was too late. Both Stephen and Carol were dead. Neither Carol nor Stephen had sustained any visible injuries and there was no obvious cause of death or weapons found nearby. Their house was immaculate and nothing appeared to be missing.
可能发生的事情，除非你彻底消灭这种疾病。请让我帮忙。把这封邮件读给她听。卡罗尔无法理性思考。”四天后的4月9日星期日，艾莉·巴克斯特来到父母家，发现他们都瘫坐在各自的躺椅上，没有反应。一位听到骚动的邻居带着艾莉的伴侣马库斯用来砸开门的爪锤冲了过来。卡罗尔和斯蒂芬摸起来都已经凉了。艾莉开始抚摸母亲的头发，恳求她醒来。救护车赶到现场，但为时已晚。斯蒂芬和卡罗尔都死了。卡罗尔和斯蒂芬身上都没有明显的伤痕，附近也没有发现明显的死因或武器。他们的房子一尘不染，似乎没有任何东西丢失。
This raised the obvious question of how two people could have died peacefully in their chairs at the same time. Ferelly Baxter, the first thing that came to her mind was that her parents could have suffered from carbon monoxide poisoning. Carbon monoxide is a gas used in household appliances that is odourless, tasteless and colourless. Therefore, when it leaks, it often goes undetected. When there is too much carbon monoxide in the air, it replaces oxygen in the body's red blood cells. is too much carbon monoxide in the air it replaces oxygen in the body's red blood cells. Symptoms appear flu-like and escalate into movement problems, memory loss, and personality changes. Those severely poisoned can lose consciousness and die, and it's the most common cause of accidental poisoning in the UK. When Ellie had discovered her parents' bodies, she threw open a set of exterior bifold doors to air out the house. On her call to emergency services, she said,
这提出了一个显而易见的问题：两个人怎么可能同时在椅子上平静地死去。对于艾莉·巴克斯特来说，她脑海中浮现的第一件事就是她的父母可能死于一氧化碳中毒。一氧化碳是一种用于家用电器中的气体，无色、无味、无臭。因此，当它泄漏时，往往无法被察觉。当空气中一氧化碳过多时，它会取代人体红细胞中的氧气。症状表现为流感样，并升级为运动障碍、记忆丧失和人格改变。严重中毒者可能会失去知觉并死亡，这是英国最常见的意外中毒原因。当艾莉发现父母的尸体时，她推开了外面的双折门来给房子通风。在给紧急服务部门打电话时，她说：
we need an ambulance right now. My mum's been poisoned. She's not very well. They're poisoned. They're dead. However, careful examination of the Baxter home failed to uncover any carbon monoxide leaks. Carol Baxter wore a pacemaker, a small device that was implanted to her chest to regulate her heartbeat. Analysis of the pacemaker revealed that her heart had stopped between 11am and 2pm on Saturday April 8, the day before her and Stephen's bodies were discovered. This narrowed down the time of death but provided no further explanation as to what had happened to the couple.
“我们现在需要一辆救护车。我妈妈中毒了。她不太好。他们中毒了。他们死了。”然而，对巴克斯特家的仔细检查未能发现任何一氧化碳泄漏。卡罗尔·巴克斯特佩戴着心脏起搏器，这是一种植入她胸部以调节心跳的小装置。对起搏器的分析显示，她的心脏在4月8日星期六上午11点到下午2点之间停止了跳动，也就是她和斯蒂芬的尸体被发现的前一天。这缩小了死亡时间，但没有对这对夫妇身上发生的事情提供进一步的解释。
All it did was rule out the possibility that Carol had died of a coronary issue, as the device would have recorded an abnormal heart rhythm. An autopsy failed to uncover any suspicious injuries, signs of abuse or defensive wounds. The couple's medical histories didn't contain any clear answers either. Stephen had recently undergone knee replacement surgery and Carol had her thyroid condition, but neither of these explained their sudden deaths. The Baxter's case was ruled unexplained but not suspicious and an inquest was scheduled for a later date.
它所做的只是排除了卡罗尔死于冠状动脉问题的可能性，因为该装置会记录下异常的心律。尸检未能发现任何可疑的伤害、虐待迹象或防御性伤口。这对夫妇的病史也没有提供任何明确的答案。斯蒂芬最近刚做了膝关节置换手术，卡罗尔有甲状腺疾病，但这些都无法解释他们突然的死亡。巴克斯特一家的案件被裁定为原因不明，但没有可疑之处，死因裁判官的调查被安排在以后的日期进行。
In the meantime, the police and coroner continued their search for answers. At the time of their deaths, 64-year-old Carol and 61-year-old Stephen were self-made millionaires. They lived comfortably in a £1 million five-bedroom home and had been members of the West Mersey Yacht Club for nearly a decade. Stephen was a senior executive with a multi-billion pound international property firm, but in recent years the couple had also established a business of their own. The idea came to Carol after they did some renovations to their bathroom and she was unable to find the right bath mat to fit their new space. And so, Kazsplash was born, a business selling
在此期间，警方和验尸官继续寻找答案。在他们去世时，64岁的卡罗尔和61岁的斯蒂芬是白手起家的百万富翁。他们舒适地住在一栋价值100万英镑的五居室住宅中，并且近十年来一直是西默西游艇俱乐部的成员。斯蒂芬是一家价值数十亿英镑的国际房地产公司的高管，但近年来这对夫妇也建立了自己的企业。这个想法是在他们对浴室进行了一些翻新，而卡罗尔无法找到合适的浴垫来适应他们的新空间后产生的。于是，Kazsplash诞生了，这是一家销售
bespoke microfibre mats to fit around curved and corner showers and baths. While Stephen had the business acumen, Carol did the designs and took on the role as Kazsplash's managing director, a dramatic but exciting pivot from her previous career in adult education. A dramatic but exciting pivot from her previous career in adult education. For all their hard work, the Baxter's always put family first. Stephen and Carol's relationship was described by those who knew them as perfect. Stephen was dedicated to his wife who he referred to as his driving force. While Carol told others that her husband worked too hard, she was never bitter about it. Stephen was a content, gentle and quiet man whose personal motto was, there are no shortcuts in life. It motivated him to work hard every day to provide
定制超细纤维垫以适应弧形和转角淋浴间及浴缸的企业。虽然斯蒂芬有商业头脑，但卡罗尔负责设计并担任Kazsplash的总经理，这是她之前在成人教育领域职业生涯的一个戏剧性但令人兴奋的转变。尽管他们付出了所有的努力，巴克斯特一家总是把家庭放在第一位。斯蒂芬和卡罗尔的关系被认识他们的人描述为完美。斯蒂芬致力于他的妻子，他称她为他的“驱动力”。虽然卡罗尔告诉别人她的丈夫工作太辛苦，但她从不为此感到痛苦。斯蒂芬是一个满足、温柔且安静的人，他的座右铭是：“生活中没有捷径。”这激励他每天努力工作以提供
for his family. The couple's two adult children, Ellie and Harry, described their parents as loving and generous. Ellie considered her mother to be her best friend and biggest supporter, and the pair enjoyed mother-daughter days shopping and going to the spa. Carol also doted on her young grandchildren, buying them toys and taking them on walks. At the time of their deaths, the couple's hard work had almost paid off. They'd been discussing downsizing to a bungalow, travelling overseas and retiring to spend more time with their family. Carol looked forward to taking art classes while Steven was excited to
给他的家庭。这对夫妇的两个成年子女，艾莉和哈里，形容他们的父母充满爱心和慷慨。艾莉认为她的母亲是她最好的朋友和最大的支持者，两人享受着母女购物和去水疗中心的时光。卡罗尔也非常疼爱她年幼的孙辈，给他们买玩具并带他们散步。在他们去世时，这对夫妇的辛勤工作几乎得到了回报。他们一直在讨论缩小住房规模搬到平房，去海外旅行，并退休以花更多时间与家人在一起。卡罗尔期待着参加艺术课程，而斯蒂芬则很兴奋能
play more golf. News of their deaths came as a complete shock to their small, close-knit community who viewed Carol and Steven as friendly and helpful people who were always there for others. By all accounts, the Baxter's were kind-hearted and selfless people with a lot to live for and exciting plans for the future together. That made the news of their untimely deaths all the more devastating. The mystery of how Carol and Stephen Baxter had died persisted until the results of their post-mortem blood tests came in. In a twist no one saw coming, both Stephen and Carol had died of a fentanyl overdose. Fentanyl is a drug that acts on the opioid receptors in the brain creating feelings of
打更多高尔夫球。他们去世的消息对他们那个关系紧密的小社区来说是一个巨大的冲击，社区成员将卡罗尔和斯蒂芬视为友好且乐于助人的人，他们总是为他人着想。据各方描述，巴克斯特夫妇是善良且无私的人，他们有很多值得活下去的理由，并对未来有着共同的令人兴奋的计划。这使得他们不合时宜的死亡消息更加令人悲痛。卡罗尔和斯蒂芬·巴克斯特是如何死亡的谜团一直持续到他们的尸检血液测试结果出来。在一个没人预料到的转折中，斯蒂芬和卡罗尔都死于芬太尼过量。芬太尼是一种作用于大脑阿片受体，产生
euphoria. Pharmaceutical fentanyl is prescribed legally for chronic pain relief as it's 80 to 100 times stronger than morphine. But it is also illicitly manufactured and sold illegally, usually as a low cost additive to increase the potency of other illicit drugs like heroin. In excess, fentanyl can reduce and disrupt the user's breathing rate resulting in what is called respiratory depression. Drug induced respiratory depression is potentially fatal, requiring specific medicines to reverse the drug's effects and restore breathing abilities.
欣快感的药物。医用芬太尼被合法开具用于慢性疼痛缓解，因为它比吗啡强80到100倍。但它也被非法制造和非法销售，通常作为降低成本的添加剂，以增加海洛因等其他非法药物的效力。过量使用芬太尼会降低并扰乱使用者的呼吸频率，导致所谓的“呼吸抑制”。药物引起的呼吸抑制具有潜在的致命性，需要特定的药物来逆转药物的影响并恢复呼吸能力。
Without them, the user can fall unconscious and die. Fentanyl is so powerful that just two milligrams of the drug can cause overdose or death. Neither Stephen nor Carol Baxter had a prescription for fentanyl or a history of taking illicit substances. There were no injection marks on either of their bodies. Carol's blood was also found to contain potentially fatal levels of promethazine, a sedating antihistamine used in many over-the-counter medications. It was difficult to imagine a scenario where two individuals who were not prescribed fentanyl could accidentally overdose on the drug. With that in mind, investigations shifted into far more sinister territory. Casefile will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors.
没有它们，使用者可能会失去知觉并死亡。芬太尼非常强大，仅两毫克的药物就可能导致过量或死亡。斯蒂芬和卡罗尔·巴克斯特都没有芬太尼的处方，也没有服用非法物质的历史。他们两人的尸体上都没有注射痕迹。卡罗尔的血液中还被发现含有潜在致命剂量的异丙嗪，这是一种用于许多非处方药中的镇静抗组胺药。很难想象两个没有被开具芬太尼处方的人会意外地过量服用这种药物。考虑到这一点，调查转向了更险恶的领域。Casefile稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集的赞助商来支持我们。
Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. Investigators considered whether the Baxter's deaths were the outcome of a suicide pact or a decision led by one onto the unsuspecting other. The couple hadn't left behind notes or anything else to indicate why they would want to prematurely end their lives. An acquaintance of Stephen's described him as being very happy and jovial in the week before his death. Yet, Carole's health had taken a sharp decline in recent years and was becoming increasingly harder to manage. It was also discovered that by April 2023, Stephen and Carole's business, Cazz Splash, was over £60,000 in debt and failing. Kaz Splash also owed a further £18,000 to the owner of the warehouse from which the business
感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Casefile继续提供高质量的内容。调查人员考虑了巴克斯特夫妇的死亡是否是自杀协议的结果，或者是由一个人引导另一个毫无戒心的人做出的决定。这对夫妇没有留下遗书或其他任何东西来表明他们为什么要过早结束自己的生命。斯蒂芬的一位熟人形容他在去世前一周非常快乐和风趣。然而，卡罗尔的健康状况近年来急剧下降，并且变得越来越难以管理。还发现，到2023年4月，斯蒂芬和卡罗尔的企业Kazsplash负债超过6万英镑，且经营不善。Kazsplash还欠仓库所有者另外1.8万英镑，该仓库是企业
operated. The last time the couple were seen alive was on Friday, April 7. A close family friend had dropped in at the Baxter home and left shortly before 8pm, at which time Carol was asleep and Stephen was preparing to make dinner. Carol's pacemaker established that her heart had stopped beating the following day, though it couldn't be ascertained when exactly Stephen had died. No one had heard from the couple in the lead up to their deaths and nothing suspicious was noted in or around their home from any of their neighbours. A security camera that filmed the front of the Baxter's property confirmed that no one had entered or exited the house on Saturday April 8. The next time the camera recorded a visitor was on Sunday April 9 when Ellie Baxter arrived and
运营的地方。这对夫妇最后一次被看到活着是在4月7日星期五。一位亲密的家庭朋友在巴克斯特家顺道拜访，并在晚上8点前离开，当时卡罗尔正在睡觉，斯蒂芬正在准备做晚饭。卡罗尔的心脏起搏器确定她的心脏在第二天停止了跳动，尽管无法确定斯蒂芬具体是在什么时候去世的。在他们去世前，没有人收到这对夫妇的消息，他们的任何邻居也没有注意到他们家中或周围有任何可疑之处。一台拍摄巴克斯特家前门的监控摄像头证实，4月8日星期六没有人进入或离开房子。摄像头记录下访客的下一次是在4月9日星期日，当时艾莉·巴克斯特到达并
found her parents dead. Still, investigators couldn't rule out the possibility that someone had snuck in through the back of the property, bypassing the camera's line of sight. A cursory examination of the Baxter's house on the day their bodies were discovered failed to uncover anything significant. As the investigation shifted towards foul play, a more thorough search took place. Investigators located a wicker box that contained Carol's prescription medication. Lying flat at the bottom were four empty packets of fentanyl patches. These patches are typically prescribed to patients who have trouble swallowing. The fentanyl inside the patch is in a gel form. It accumulates in the skin below the patch
发现她的父母死了。尽管如此，调查人员无法排除有人从房产后方潜入，避开了摄像头的视线。在发现尸体当天对巴克斯特家进行的初步检查未能发现任何重大发现。随着调查转向谋杀，进行了更彻底的搜查。调查人员找到了一个装有卡罗尔处方药的柳条盒。平放在底部的是四个空的芬太尼贴片包装。这些贴片通常开给有吞咽困难的病人。贴片内的芬太尼呈凝胶状。它积聚在贴片下方的皮肤中
before gradually entering the user's circulation, providing pain relief for 72 hours. The patches were a curious find given that neither Stephen, Carol nor anyone else in their immediate circle had a prescription for them. Their bodies didn't feature any markings indicating they'd applied the patches in the lead up to their deaths. Stranger still, the evidence suggests that the couple had ingested the fatal fentanyl doses orally. It wasn't unusual for fentanyl patches to be misused in this way. People were known to cut them into pieces and suck on them, while others removed the gel and let it dry into a powder that could be consumed in different ways. Given that fentanyl doesn't have a taste or smell, it can be concealed in nasal sprays, eyedrops, and small candies.
然后逐渐进入使用者的循环系统，提供72小时的疼痛缓解。考虑到斯蒂芬、卡罗尔或他们亲密圈子里的任何其他人都没有这些贴片的处方，这些贴片是一个奇怪的发现。他们的尸体上没有任何迹象表明他们在去世前贴过这些贴片。更奇怪的是，证据表明这对夫妇是口服了致命剂量的芬太尼。芬太尼贴片以这种方式被滥用并不罕见。人们已知会将它们切成碎片并吮吸，而其他人则取出凝胶并让其干燥成粉末，可以通过不同方式食用。鉴于芬太尼没有味道或气味，它可以隐藏在鼻喷雾剂、滴眼液和小糖果中。
it can be concealed in nasal sprays, eyedrops, and small candies. Another method colloquially known as fentanyl infusion involved dissolving the drug in a cup of tea for a longer lasting effect. It couldn't be ascertained what state the fentanyl was in when the Baxter's ingested it, such as powder or liquid. None of the couple's cookware, utensils or glassware contained traces of the drug, and not even a single cup was out of place. This raised the question of how the drug had been prepared, served and consumed without any evidence being left behind. The way the patches were positioned in Carol's medication box was also strange. While the rest of the box was neatly arranged, the patches stood out as loose. First responders had inspected the box when they were called to the house to determine if Carol's medication could be linked to the
它可以隐藏在鼻喷雾剂、滴眼液和小糖果中。另一种俗称为“芬太尼输液”的方法涉及将药物溶解在茶杯中以获得更持久的效果。无法确定巴克斯特夫妇摄入芬太尼时它处于什么状态，例如粉末或液体。这对夫妇的任何炊具、餐具或玻璃器皿都没有药物痕迹，甚至连一个杯子都没有放错位置。这提出了一个问题：药物是如何在没有留下任何证据的情况下被准备、供应和消费的。贴片在卡罗尔药盒中的位置也很奇怪。虽然盒子的其余部分排列整齐，但贴片显得很松散。急救人员在被叫到房子时检查了盒子，以确定卡罗尔的药物是否与
deaths. They didn't see the fentanyl patches at the time. During a more thorough search of the Baxter's home, an item was found in Carol's home office that hadn't been noticed the first time. It was a printed document that featured uppercase text spread out over multiple dot points. The top of the page read, in the event of our deaths, followed by the names Steven and Carol Baxter. It was determined to be a codicil, a legal document that acts as a supplement to a final will and testament. It allows people to make changes to their will without the time consuming task of having to rewrite the entire original document. Although codicels are typically more common for handwritten wills, they are still considered useful to make small updates.
死亡有关。他们当时没有看到芬太尼贴片。在对巴克斯特家进行更彻底的搜查时，在卡罗尔的家庭办公室里发现了一件第一次没有被注意到的物品。那是一份打印的文件，上面有分布在多个项目符号上的大写文本。页面顶部写着“在我们去世的情况下”，后面跟着斯蒂芬和卡罗尔·巴克斯特的名字。它被确定为遗嘱附录，这是一种作为最终遗嘱和遗嘱补充的法律文件。它允许人们在不进行重写整个原始文件的耗时任务的情况下更改他们的遗嘱。虽然遗嘱附录通常在手写遗嘱中更为常见，但它们仍被认为对进行小幅更新很有用。
The Baxter's codicel went on to explain what to do with their house and belongings, as well as their desire to have their wake take place at the West Mersey Yacht Club. The document also addressed the couple's business, explaining, "...Casplash is to continue trading in whichever way is planned. Our daughter, Ellie Baxter, is to be the 100% shareholder and complete owner. There is no financial gain to this. Our dear friend, Luke DeWitt, is to be the director and person with significant control. All business-making decisions are down to him, apart from an agreed and respected wage. There is no financial gain to this.
巴克斯特夫妇的遗嘱附录继续解释了如何处理他们的房子和财物，以及他们希望在西默西游艇俱乐部举行守灵仪式的愿望。该文件还提到了这对夫妇的企业，解释说：“……Kazsplash将继续以计划的任何方式进行交易。我们的女儿艾莉·巴克斯特将成为100%的股东和完全所有者。这没有任何经济收益。我们亲爱的朋友卢克·德威特将成为董事和具有重大控制权的人。所有的商业决策都由他决定，除了商定和尊重的工资。这没有任何经济收益。”
When Ellie becomes of the age of 30, the directorship is to be split 50-50 between Ellie and Luke. Ellie is to then become the person of significant control but cannot remove Luke of his directorship. Business decisions are to be made jointly between the two. Grant of £60,000 from the estate of Stephen and Carol Baxter is to be given to the business to develop new ideas and continue the support of the business. The document ended with the date of November 22, 2022, almost four and a half months before the Baxters died, along with the line, agreed by Stephen and Carol. Agreed by Stephen and Carol. The document was intriguing. At no point did it refer to the Baxter's existing will which had been approved and signed in September 2021. In that will, they'd left all their money to their
当艾莉年满30岁时，董事职位将由艾莉和卢克平分。艾莉随后将成为具有重大控制权的人，但不能免除卢克的董事职务。商业决策将由两人共同做出。从斯蒂芬和卡罗尔·巴克斯特的遗产中拨出6万英镑赠款给企业，以开发新想法并继续支持企业。文件以2022年11月22日的日期结束，即巴克斯特夫妇去世前大约四个半月，并附有一行字：“由斯蒂芬和卡罗尔同意。”该文件很耐人寻味。它在任何时候都没有提到巴克斯特夫妇现有的遗嘱，该遗嘱已于2021年9月获得批准并签署。在那份遗嘱中，他们将所有的钱留给了他们的
children, the two they had together, and two more Carol had from a previous relationship. While the original will didn't include specific arrangements for the running of Casplash, it designated Carol's sister and her husband as executors of the business. Furthermore, a codicil has to follow formalities laid out in the Wills Act 1837, yet Stephen and Carol's did not. In fact, the document fulfilled none of the required criteria. Neither Stephen nor Carol had signed the codicil and it didn't feature the necessary signatures of two individual witnesses. As such, the document purporting to be a codicil was not legally binding and therefore not a codicil at all. In the words of Stephen and Carol's solicitor who had drafted their original will,
孩子，他们共同拥有的两个孩子，以及卡罗尔从前一段关系中带来的另外两个孩子。虽然原始遗嘱没有包括关于Kazsplash运营的具体安排，但它指定了卡罗尔的妹妹和她的丈夫作为企业的执行人。此外，遗嘱附录必须遵循1837年《遗嘱法》规定的形式，但斯蒂芬和卡罗尔的遗嘱附录却没有。事实上，该文件没有满足任何要求的标准。斯蒂芬和卡罗尔都没有签署该遗嘱附录，也没有两位个人证人的必要签名。因此，这份声称是遗嘱附录的文件在法律上不具有约束力，因此根本不是遗嘱附录。用起草他们原始遗嘱的斯蒂芬和卡罗尔的律师的话来说，
the codicil had no logic to it. He said, The document is odd, the wording is odd, it is not signed, it is not laid out in a legal format, and it doesn't read as a legal document. I haven't seen the document before. Carol nor Stephen had attempted to change their will with my firm. There's no record of anyone making contact in order to make changes to wills. Aside from Stephen and Carol, the codicil only named two other people, one of whom was Ellie Baxter. Ellie admitted there had been arguments within her family about her parents' will in recent times, and the codicil was along the lines of conversations she had with her parents prior
该遗嘱附录没有任何逻辑。他说：“这份文件很奇怪，措辞很奇怪，它没有签名，没有以法律格式排版，读起来也不像法律文件。我以前没见过这份文件。卡罗尔和斯蒂芬都没有尝试过通过我的公司更改他们的遗嘱。没有任何记录显示有人联系过以更改遗嘱。”除了斯蒂芬和卡罗尔，遗嘱附录只提到了另外两个人，其中一个是艾莉·巴克斯特。艾莉承认，最近一段时间她的家人关于她父母的遗嘱有过争论，而遗嘱附录的内容与她父母去世前与她进行的谈话内容一致。短信似乎证实了这一点。在其中一条中，卡罗尔告诉艾莉，Kazsplash“在某个时候会完全属于你”。然而，在同一条信息中，卡罗尔表达了对艾莉对企业表现出如此少兴趣的沮丧。在过去的一年里，艾莉只工作了四天，她经常需要向别人借钱。卡罗尔担心她女儿管理财务的能力，并给她发了一条信息，上面写着：“‘你得到钱后不看管它。’”艾莉声称她不知道Kazsplash负债累累。在她父母去世后，她一直与
to their deaths. Text messages seemed to confirm this. In one, Carol told Ellie that Cazz Splash would, quote, be all yours at some point. Yet, in the same messages, Carol expressed frustration at how little interest Ellie had shown towards the business. Over the past year, Ellie had only worked four days and she often needed to borrow money from others. Carol was concerned about her daughter's ability to manage finances and she sent her a message which read, "'You don't look after money when you get it.'" Ellie claimed that she was unaware that Casplash was in debt. Since her parents' deaths, she had been in
一位名叫马丁·埃里森的律师保持联系，他证实他起草了该遗嘱附录并支持其真实性。文件中提到的另一个人是一个名叫卢克·德威特的人。斯蒂芬和卡罗尔在2014年遇到卢克，当时他回应了一则寻求帮助为他们的企业建立网站的广告。卢克·德威特拥有计算机科学硕士学位，并以诚实可靠而闻名，是一位值得雇佣的人。卢克是默西的终身居民，他与父母住在一起，为当地的嘉年华工作，并在救济厨房做志愿者。他性格内向、温和，比起与同龄人社交或攀登
contact with a solicitor named Martin Ellison, who confirmed that he'd constructed the codicil and supported its authenticity. The only other person mentioned in the document was a man named Luke DeWitt. Stephen and Carol had met Luke in 2014 after he responded to an ad seeking help setting up a website for their business. With a master's in computer science and a reputation for being honest and reliable, Luke DeWitt was a worthy hire. Luke was a lifelong resident of Mersey where he lived with his parents, worked for the local carnival and volunteered at a soup kitchen. Introverted and mild-mannered, he preferred playing simulation video games and attending comic book conventions over socialising with his peers or climbing a
企业阶梯，他更喜欢玩模拟视频游戏和参加漫画书大会。他对外表上的金钱或积累财富没有兴趣，而是利用他对IT的热情来设计和管理几家当地企业和慈善机构的网站，包括帮助该地区不幸者的狮子会。虽然卢克是那种在工作会议期间安静地坐在角落里的人，但同事们发现他很体贴，总是愿意提供支持。他非常有社区意识，很受欢迎，并参与了岛上的许多项目。一位同事这样评价卢克：“如果你需要帮助，他就在那里。他是第一个说‘好吧，我能做什么？’的人。他
corporate ladder. He showed no outward interest in money or accumulating wealth, instead using his passion for IT to design and manage the websites of several local businesses and charities, including the Lions Club, who helped the less fortunate in the area. Although Luke was the type to sit quietly in the corner during work meetings, colleagues found him considerate and always willing to offer his support. He was very community-orientated, well-liked, and involved in lots of projects on the island. One colleague said of Luke, if you need help he is there. He's the first person to say right, what can I do? He
活着就是为了在人们需要帮助时参与其中。”卢克是通过一位共同的朋友被介绍给巴克斯特一家的，之后他被聘为Kazsplash的IT顾问。他每周工作两天，时薪约为15英镑。随着时间的推移，他变得深度参与并投资于该企业。斯蒂芬和卡罗尔开始觉得Kazsplash在卢克手中很安全。他获得了电子邮件和银行账户的访问权限，并参与了将事情引向新方向的讨论。卡罗尔为卢克资助了不同的培训课程
lives to be involved where people need help. Luke was introduced to the Baxter's through a mutual friend before he was taken on board as Kaz Splash's IT consultant. He was paid around £15 an hour for two days a week work. In time, he became heavily involved and invested in the business. Stephen and Carol came to feel that Casplash was in good hands with Luke. He was given access to emails and bank accounts and participated in discussions to take things in a new direction. Carol financed different training courses for Luke
以便他能进一步提升自己的技能，而有一次卢克借给Kazsplash 1.5万英镑以促进其发展。当卢克的父亲在2021年与癌症长期斗争后去世时，他似乎变得非常孤独。巴克斯特一家将他纳入羽翼之下，让他参加他们的家庭晚餐和其他特殊场合。他通过成为卡罗尔的某种照顾者来回报他们的善意，这个角色减轻了其他人的压力，并给了卢克目标。这是一个他认真对待的特权。他获得了巴克斯特家前门的安保密码，以及一个钥匙保险箱的位置，这样他可以随时查看卡罗尔的情况。他开始每天去他们家帮忙做家务并管理卡罗尔的症状。他负责分发她的药物，
so that he could further his skill set, while at one stage Luke loaned Casplash £15,000 to foster its growth. When Luke's father passed away in 2021 after a long battle with cancer, he seemed to become incredibly lonely. The Baxter's took him under their wing, including him in their family dinners and other special occasions. He paid back their kindness by becoming somewhat of a carer for Carole, a role which alleviated pressures off others and gave Luke purpose. It was a privilege he took seriously. He was given the security code to the Baxter's front gate, as well as the location of a key safe so he could check in on Carole at any time. as well as the location of a key safe so he could check in on Carol at any time. He began visiting their home daily to help with chores and manage Carol's symptoms. He administered her medication,
以便他能进一步提升自己的技能，而卢克甚至曾一度借给Casplash 1.5万英镑以促进其发展。2021年，卢克的父亲在与癌症长期抗争后去世，他似乎变得异常孤独。巴克斯特一家对他关怀备至，邀请他参加家庭聚餐和其他特殊场合。为了报答他们的善意，他成为了卡罗尔的照料者，这一角色减轻了其他人的压力，也让卢克找到了生活的目标。他非常认真地对待这份殊荣。他被告知了巴克斯特家前门的安保密码，以及钥匙保险箱的位置，这样他就可以随时去探望卡罗尔。他开始每天去他们家帮忙做家务，并协助管理卡罗尔的症状。他负责为她分发药物。
escorted her on her walks and took her to the gym. It was Luke who had done the research that led Carol to renowned endocrinologist Dr. Andrea Bowden. The Baxter's came to rely on Luke immensely. He told others that he felt like their adopted son. When Luke confided in the couple that he had been diagnosed with bone marrow cancer, they rallied around him. He was given the support and flexibility needed to attend all his chemotherapy appointments without fear of losing his job. When he came back from the hospital complaining of headaches and fatigue, the Baxter's took care of him. By April 2023, 34-year-old Luke had been in the Baxter's life for nine years and was considered to be a part of the family.
陪她散步，带她去健身房。正是卢克做了研究，才让卡罗尔找到了著名的内分泌学家安德里亚·鲍登医生。巴克斯特夫妇非常依赖卢克。他告诉别人，他感觉自己就像他们的养子。当卢克向这对夫妇吐露自己被诊断出患有骨髓癌时，他们团结在了一起支持他。他获得了所需的支持和灵活性，可以去参加所有的化疗预约，而不必担心失去工作。当他从医院回来抱怨头痛和疲劳时，巴克斯特夫妇照顾了他。到2023年4月，34岁的卢克已经在巴克斯特的生活中待了九年，被视为家庭的一员。
in the Baxter's life for nine years and was considered to be a part of the family. Therefore, Luke's presence in the codicil wasn't all that unusual. He had earned Steven and Carol's trust and was a major part of Cas Splash's day-to-day workings, more so than anyone else. Ellie Baxter had known Luke DeWitt since she was a teenager and had come to view him like a brother. If she asked to borrow money from him, he never said no. Over the years, Luke had loaned Ellie over £7,000. On the day that Ellie had discovered her parents' lifeless bodies, Luke was the first person that Ellie's partner, Marcus, had called. lifeless bodies, Luke was the first person that Ellie's partner Marcus had called. Luke only lived a short distance away and he'd rushed to the Baxter's home to find Ellie on the phone to emergency services frantically screaming, they're dead, they're dead.
在巴克斯特的生活中待了九年，被视为家庭的一员。因此，卢克出现在遗嘱附录中并不算太不寻常。他赢得了史蒂文和卡罗尔的信任，是Cas Splash日常运作的主要部分，比任何人都重要。艾莉·巴克斯特从十几岁起就认识卢克·德威特，并把他看作兄弟。如果她向他借钱，他从不拒绝。多年来，卢克借给艾莉超过7000英镑。在艾莉发现父母冰冷尸体的那天，卢克是艾莉的伴侣马库斯打给的第一个人。冰冷的尸体，卢克是艾莉的伴侣马库斯打给的第一个人。卢克住得不远，他冲到巴克斯特家，发现艾莉正对着电话向紧急服务部门疯狂尖叫，他们死了，他们死了。
Ellie had been so distraught that the operator on the other line couldn't understand her. Luke had taken over the call, introducing himself as a friend of Stephen and Carol's, before calmly explaining, We've just turned up to their house. We hadn't heard anything from anyone for about a day and a half. We came around and their daughter got here first, got to their conservatory, and they were sitting in their armchairs not moving. We smashed the window to get in, but they're just cold." Luke said that Stephen and Carol appeared to be beyond help. He described Ellie as being devastated and was overheard telling the others, "...it could be gas or something. When paramedics arrived, Luke gathered all of Carol's medication in a box for them to
艾莉非常心烦意乱，以至于电话另一头的接线员听不懂她在说什么。卢克接过了电话，介绍自己是史蒂芬和卡罗尔的朋友，然后冷静地解释说：“我们刚到他们家。我们已经有一天半没收到任何人的消息了。我们过来时，他们的女儿先到了，到了他们的温室，他们坐在扶手椅上，一动不动。我们砸碎了窗户进去，但他们已经凉了。”卢克说史蒂芬和卡罗尔看起来已经没救了。他形容艾莉非常崩溃，并被听到对其他人说：“……可能是煤气之类的。”当医护人员到达时，卢克把卡罗尔所有的药物收集在一个盒子里给他们
assess. He also willingly provided a comprehensive statement to police that was recorded on an officer's body-worn camera. While Luke described himself as Carol's closest friend, he said Stephen mostly kept to himself. Pondering the possible cause of their deaths, Luke told police about the medication Carole took for her thyroid condition, explaining, "...unfortunately with Carole, you don't know what she's taken. Sometimes she forgets and she can take it six or seven times. She doesn't know." Sometimes she forgets and she can take it six or seven times. She doesn't know.
评估。他还主动向警方提供了全面的陈述，并被记录在警官的随身摄像机上。虽然卢克称自己是卡罗尔最亲密的朋友，但他表示史蒂芬大多独来独往。在思考他们死亡的可能原因时，卢克告诉警方卡罗尔因甲状腺疾病服用的药物，解释说：“……不幸的是，对于卡罗尔，你不知道她吃了什么。有时她会忘记，可能会吃六七次。她不知道。”有时她会忘记，可能会吃六七次。她不知道。
Luke said he'd visited the couple on Friday evening and had left at around 7.55pm. He locked the front door behind him and went straight home to watch television. He didn't visit the Baxter's the next day because they'd wanted time to themselves. Instead, he'd spent the day going to the gym, catching up with a friend, and taking his mother out for ice cream. That night, he went out for dinner with Ellie and Marcus. Although the lack of communication from the Baxter's was making him uneasy, Luke said he didn't return to their house until Sunday when Marcus summoned him there. The Baxter's outdoor security camera confirmed to Luke's account, having recorded him leaving the house at 7.55pm on the Friday. With their time of death determined
卢克说他周五晚上拜访了这对夫妇，大约晚上7点55分离开。他锁上前门，直接回家看电视。第二天他没有去拜访巴克斯特夫妇，因为他们想有自己的时间。相反，他花了一天时间去健身房，和朋友叙旧，带母亲去吃冰淇淋。那天晚上，他和艾莉及马库斯一起出去吃晚饭。虽然巴克斯特夫妇缺乏沟通让他感到不安，但卢克说直到周日马库斯叫他去，他才回到他们家。巴克斯特家的户外监控摄像头证实了卢克的说法，记录下他在周五晚上7点55分离开房子。随着他们的死亡时间被确定
to be between 11am and 2pm on Saturday April 8, this made him the last person to have seen Stephen and Carol alive. Luke's whereabouts for the Saturday were checked and verified, prompting investigators to view him as just a witness and not at all suspicious. But when the police spoke to the Baxter's neighbours, they divulged something odd. Luke DeWitt had apparently asked if they had any CCTV footage that captured the Baxter's house. He said he wanted to see it because he was expecting a delivery at their address that hadn't arrived.
在4月8日星期六上午11点到下午2点之间，这使他成为最后一个见到史蒂芬和卡罗尔活着的人。卢克周六的行踪经过核实，促使调查人员将他视为证人，并没有任何可疑之处。但当警方与巴克斯特家的邻居交谈时，他们透露了一些奇怪的事情。卢克·德威特显然问过他们是否有拍到巴克斯特家的监控录像。他说他想看，因为他期待着一个送到他们地址的快递，但一直没到。
This raised immediate suspicions for the police. What if the real reason Luke wanted the footage was because there was something on it that he didn't want anyone else to see? Meanwhile, the pregnant Ellie Baxter felt as though her insides were on fire. The trauma of finding her parents' bodies had caused her to begin bleeding heavily. She feared she was having a miscarriage, but a checkup confirmed her baby was okay. In the ensuing weeks, as the police continued their investigations into how the deaths occurred, Ellie took extra care to avoid stress to prevent harming her unborn child. She set about organising her parents' funeral with help from Luke DeWitt,
这引起了警方的立即怀疑。如果卢克想要录像的真正原因是因为上面有什么他不想让别人看到的东西呢？与此同时，怀孕的艾莉·巴克斯特感觉五脏六腑都在燃烧。发现父母尸体的创伤导致她开始大量出血。她担心自己流产了，但检查证实她的宝宝没事。在随后的几周里，随着警方继续调查死亡原因，艾莉格外小心，避免压力，以免伤害未出生的孩子。她在卢克·德威特的帮助下开始筹备父母的葬礼，
who joined her as she spoke with the celebrant. He helped pick out the flowers and even looked after Ellie's other young son so she could attend antenatal appointments. According to Ellie, Luke was a tower of strength during those difficult times. Luke was a tower of strength during those difficult times. Although she was grateful for his support, Ellie knew that the relationship between Luke and her parents had been fraught. For all the good he did, the Baxter's and their loved ones found Luke's overt and controlling presence in their lives to be weird. He made excuses to visit their house daily, sometimes arriving completely unannounced despite being told not to. They also questioned his work ethic. Despite the Baxter's giving Luke the opportunity to grow and develop with Casplash,
他陪着她与司仪交谈。他帮忙挑选鲜花，甚至照顾艾莉的另一个年幼的儿子，这样她就可以去参加产前检查。据艾莉说，卢克在那些困难时期是坚强的后盾。卢克在那些困难时期是坚强的后盾。虽然她很感激他的支持，但艾莉知道卢克和她父母之间的关系一直很紧张。尽管他做了很多好事，但巴克斯特夫妇和他们的亲人发现卢克在他们生活中那种公开且具有控制欲的存在很奇怪。他每天找借口去他们家，有时尽管被告知不要来，却完全不请自来。他们还质疑他的职业道德。尽管巴克斯特夫妇给了卢克在Casplash成长和发展的机会，
he didn't seem interested in doing more than the basics. Stephen Baxter had been getting particularly fed up with Luke and how upset he was making his already frail wife. Stephen sought advice from one of the only people who knew the personal ins and outs of their family dynamic, endocrinologist Dr Andrea Bowden. In emails to Dr Bowden, Stephen wrote that Luke overstayed his welcome, took advantage of their hospitality, and played silly mind games with Carol. He was always asking what Carol was doing and where she was going, and sometimes Carol felt Luke was following her.
他似乎对做基本工作以外的事情不感兴趣。史蒂芬·巴克斯特对卢克越来越厌烦，也对他让本已虚弱的妻子如此心烦意乱感到不满。史蒂芬向唯一了解他们家庭动态内幕的人之一，内分泌学家安德里亚·鲍登医生寻求建议。在给鲍登医生的电子邮件中，史蒂芬写道，卢克不请自来，利用他们的好客，并和卡罗尔玩愚蠢的心理游戏。他总是问卡罗尔在做什么，要去哪里，有时卡罗尔觉得卢克在跟踪她。
While acknowledging that Carol really loved Luke, Stephen admitted that the two men weren't as close and had a different relationship. Stephen told Dr. Bowden that they needed a break. Dr. Bowden responded, I'm aware of Luke's faults, but he does seem like a lovely lad. I did tell him to avoid you both for a few days to have some time away from him. He has messaged me before to say he stays with Carol sometimes to give you a rest, so he clearly cares for you. He is one reason you still have a wife. He is changing as a person,
虽然承认卡罗尔真的很喜欢卢克，但史蒂芬承认这两个男人并不亲近，关系也不同。史蒂芬告诉鲍登医生，他们需要休息一下。鲍登医生回应说：“我知道卢克的缺点，但他看起来是个可爱的孩子。我确实告诉过他避开你们俩几天，让你们和他保持距离。他以前给我发过信息说他有时会和卡罗尔待在一起，让你们休息一下，所以他显然很关心你们。他是你们还能拥有妻子的原因之一。他正在改变，
and you have a newfound relationship." Prior to their deaths, Stephen and Carol had started distancing themselves from Luke. They asked Ellie to collect all their business passwords that were in Luke's control because they intended to fire him. They feared he'd react poorly and shut down KazSplash's IT network, destroying years of records and data. Even with police suspicion being geared towards Luke DeWitt, investigators were keeping an open mind. The non-legal codicil had also drawn reasonable suspicion against Ellie Baxter. Police theorised that the two could have been plotting together to get Stephen and Carol out of the picture so they could benefit financially from their deaths. Given that Ellie had been with
你们有了新的关系。”在他们去世之前，史蒂芬和卡罗尔已经开始疏远卢克。他们要求艾莉收集所有在卢克控制下的业务密码，因为他们打算解雇他。他们担心他会反应激烈，关闭KazSplash的IT网络，销毁多年的记录和数据。即使警方对卢克·德威特产生了怀疑，调查人员也保持开放的态度。那份非法律效力的遗嘱附录也引起了对艾莉·巴克斯特的合理怀疑。警方推测，两人可能一直在密谋，想让史蒂芬和卡罗尔出局，这样他们就能从他们的死亡中获得经济利益。鉴于艾莉当时和
her partner Marcus at the time the deaths occurred, police also suspected that he could be an accomplice. In June 2023, two months after the deaths of Stephen and Carol Baxter, police arrived at Ellie's front door and placed her under arrest for the murder of her parents. Her partner Marcus and Luke DeWitt were also arrested. Ellie who was six months pregnant was distraught. She firmly denied having any involvement in her parents' deaths, insisting she didn't even know they'd died as a result of a fentanyl overdose until police told her during her arrest interview. After six hours of questioning, Ellie and Marcus were released from custody.
她的伴侣马库斯在一起，警方也怀疑他可能是同谋。2023年6月，在史蒂芬和卡罗尔·巴克斯特去世两个月后，警方来到艾莉家门口，以谋杀父母的罪名逮捕了她。她的伴侣马库斯和卢克·德威特也被逮捕。怀孕六个月的艾莉心烦意乱。她坚决否认参与了父母的死亡，坚称直到逮捕审讯时警方告诉她，她才知道他们死于芬太尼过量。经过六个小时的审讯，艾莉和马库斯被释放。
Luke DeWitt, however, remained behind. Unbeknownst to the trio, police had been doing multiple searches and had made some major discoveries. Casefile will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. At the time of his arrest, Luke DeWitt was in possession of a rucksack that contained multiple opened and unopened fentanyl patches. The patches had been prescribed to his late father during his battle with cancer two years
然而，卢克·德威特留了下来。三人组不知道的是，警方一直在进行多次搜查，并有一些重大发现。Casefile稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Casefile继续提供高质量的内容。在被捕时，卢克·德威特随身携带一个背包，里面装有多个已开封和未开封的芬太尼贴片。这些贴片是他已故父亲在两年前与癌症抗争时被开具的
prior. A search of Luke's home turned up even more fentanyl patches. Luke explained he'd been going through his dad's belongings very, very slowly and had been collecting the patches whenever he found them. He claimed he intended to dispose of them at a pharmacy but hadn't gotten around to it yet. The patches were compared to the ones found in Carol Baxter's medicine box, and they all featured the same batch number. Luke's fingerprints were also found on the packets. In Luke's rucksack, police also found an abundance of phenurgan, an over-the-counter
处方药。对卢克家的搜查发现了更多的芬太尼贴片。卢克解释说，他一直在非常非常缓慢地整理父亲的遗物，每当发现贴片时就会收集起来。他声称他打算在药店处理掉它们，但一直没腾出时间。这些贴片与在卡罗尔·巴克斯特的药盒中发现的进行了比对，它们都具有相同的批号。卢克的指纹也在包装上被发现。在卢克的背包里，警方还发现了大量的非那根，这是一种非处方
antihistamine that contained promethazine, the drug found in excessive amounts in Carol Baxter's blood. the drug found in excessive amounts in Carol Baxter's blood. The Phanergan tablets had been crushed into a powder using a makeshift pestle and mortar found amongst Luke's belongings. Luke asserted that he had ground up the Phanergan so he could mix the powder with a cream to treat eczema. Investigators weren't convinced. Another bag was found at the foot of Luke's bed, which contained multiple empty pill capsules. Luke insisted the bag wasn't his. He claimed he'd taken it from the Cas Splash office, implying it belonged to either Steven or Carol Baxter. But with all this evidence coming to light, police believed the most likely explanation was that Luke had placed the crushed Phenurgan into the capsules, creating a potent and deadly pill that
抗组胺药，含有异丙嗪，这是在卡罗尔·巴克斯特血液中发现过量的药物。这是在卡罗尔·巴克斯特血液中发现过量的药物。非那根药片被用在卢克物品中发现的简易研钵和研杵压碎成粉末。卢克断言他磨碎非那根是为了将其与乳霜混合治疗湿疹。调查人员并不相信。在卢克的床脚发现另一个袋子，里面装有多个空药囊。卢克坚称这个袋子不是他的。他声称是从Cas Splash办公室拿的，暗示它属于史蒂芬或卡罗尔·巴克斯特。但随着所有这些证据浮出水面，警方认为最可能的解释是卢克将压碎的非那根放入胶囊中，制造了一种强效且致命的药丸，
contained four times the therapeutic dose of Promethazine. The bag found in Luke's bedroom also contained dozens of metal nails. They were a match to the one that had inexplicably been found in Carol's colon the year before her death. It appeared that Luke had secured the nail inside a capsule and somehow fed it to Carol, a move that could have very well killed her. Police uncovered 80 electronic devices belonging to Luke DeWitt, including multiple mobile phones, smartwatches, iPads, laptops, computers, hard drives and USB sticks. Some of the phones were unregistered and featured SIM cards that enabled the user to buy telephone numbers from over 80 different countries. These foreign numbers could then be used to make calls and send texts as though they were coming from that country.
含有四倍于治疗剂量的异丙嗪。在卢克卧室发现的袋子里还装有几十枚金属钉。它们与前一年在卡罗尔结肠中莫名发现的那枚钉子相吻合。看来卢克把钉子固定在胶囊里，并以某种方式喂给了卡罗尔，这一举动很可能杀死了她。警方发现了80台属于卢克·德威特的电子设备，包括多部手机、智能手表、iPad、笔记本电脑、电脑、硬盘和USB闪存盘。其中一些手机未注册，并配有SIM卡，允许用户从80多个不同国家购买电话号码。这些外国号码随后可以用来拨打电话和发送短信，就像来自那个国家一样。
It took thousands of hours to meticulously analyse the extensive data across all of Luke's digital devices. Investigators were astounded at what they uncovered. It turned out that Luke had created at least 20 online personas that he'd been using to communicate with Stephen, Carol, and Ellie Baxter over several years. It was clear from the long history of interactions on both WhatsApp and in emails that the Baxter family had no idea they were actually messaging Luke DeWitt that entire time. The first and most abhorrent persona Luke had created was renowned endocrinologist Dr Andrea Bowden, who he used to exert complete control over Carol. Characters such as Cheryl Herring, Linda Edwards Edwards and Marnie Pantry had
花费了数千小时来仔细分析卢克所有数字设备上的海量数据。调查人员对他们发现的内容感到震惊。事实证明，卢克创建了至少20个在线角色，多年来一直用这些角色与史蒂芬、卡罗尔和艾莉·巴克斯特交流。从WhatsApp和电子邮件中长期的互动历史来看，很明显巴克斯特一家在那整个时间里根本不知道他们实际上是在给卢克·德威特发信息。卢克创建的第一个也是最令人厌恶的角色是著名的内分泌学家安德里亚·鲍登医生，他利用这个角色完全控制了卡罗尔。像谢丽尔·赫林、琳达·爱德华兹和玛妮·潘特里这样的角色
been created to verify Dr. Bowden's credentials and to persuade and pressure Carol to follow her rules. Dr. Bowden's instructions started out innocuous enough, like advising Carol not to overexert herself by doing housework, but they gradually became more calculating. With Luke acting as the puppet master, Dr. Bowden steered Carol away from her GP, family, friends, and support network. When Carol started having doubts about Dr. Bowden's treatment at one point, Luke invented Dr. Alan Mandel to get her back on side. Ellie Baxter had watched as her already fragile mother was severely harmed by Dr Bowden's influence, explaining, Mum felt so alone and lost and there was nothing I could do other than give her my shoulder to cry on
被创建出来以验证鲍登医生的资历，并说服和施压卡罗尔遵守她的规则。鲍登医生的指示起初看起来无伤大雅，比如建议卡罗尔不要做家务过度劳累，但逐渐变得更加处心积虑。在卢克作为幕后操纵者的情况下，鲍登医生引导卡罗尔远离她的全科医生、家人、朋友和支持网络。当卡罗尔有一次开始怀疑鲍登医生的治疗时，卢克发明了艾伦·曼德尔医生来让她回心转意。艾莉·巴克斯特看着她本已脆弱的母亲被鲍登医生的影响严重伤害，解释说：“妈妈感到如此孤独和迷茫，除了给她肩膀哭泣，我什么也做不了
and cuddle her. Ellie had encouraged Carol to go back and see her GP, but she'd refused. In Ellie's words, her mother was completely brainwashed by Dr. Bowden. It didn't stop there. Luke had also created friends and family of these fake women to further bolster his con, such as Jenny Trencher, the theatre producer based in London. Luke's online browsing history showed that he'd once searched for instructions on how to change voice on a live call. Audio recordings found on his phone captured him practising a voice for Jenny, seemingly in preparation for having to speak to Carol over the phone while using the Jenny persona. Hi, Carol. It's Jenny. It's Jenny. Hi, Carol. It's Jenny. It's Cheryl's sister.
并拥抱她。”艾莉曾鼓励卡罗尔回去看她的全科医生，但她拒绝了。用艾莉的话说，她母亲被鲍登医生彻底洗脑了。这还没完。卢克还创建了这些假女人的朋友和家人来进一步支持他的骗局，比如住在伦敦的戏剧制作人珍妮·特伦彻。卢克的在线浏览记录显示，他曾经搜索过关于如何在实时通话中改变声音的说明。在他手机上发现的录音捕捉到他为珍妮练习声音，似乎是为了准备在以珍妮的身份与卡罗尔通电话时使用。嗨，卡罗尔。我是珍妮。我是珍妮。嗨，卡罗尔。我是珍妮。我是谢丽尔的妹妹。
Yes, oh, it's so nice to finally speak to you after all these messages we've been doing. Ellie Baxter had formed a close friendship with the Jenny Trencher on the misguided belief that she could further her singing career. At one point, the pair exchanged messages daily, in which Ellie disclosed the difficulties her family were facing regarding her parents' will. All the while, she was completely oblivious to the fact that she was actually passing on this personal information to Luke DeWitt. When Carol and Stephen died, Ellie informed Jenny, who replied in a message, Oh no my darling sweetheart, I'm so sorry. Ellie continued to receive communication from the online identities right up until Luke
是的，哦，在经过我们这么多次信息交流后，终于能和你说话真是太好了。艾莉·巴克斯特在误以为可以促进她歌唱事业的错误信念下，与珍妮·特伦彻建立了亲密的友谊。有一次，两人每天交换信息，艾莉在信息中透露了她家在父母遗嘱方面面临的困难。与此同时，她完全不知道自己实际上是在把这些个人信息传递给卢克·德威特。当卡罗尔和史蒂芬去世时，艾莉通知了珍妮，珍妮在信息中回复道：“哦，不，我亲爱的甜心，我太难过了。”艾莉一直收到来自这些在线身份的通讯，直到卢克
DeWitt's arrest, at which point they stopped abruptly. When she learned the truth about who was behind the personas, Ellie was beside herself. Jenny was a trusted person, she said. I thought she was there to help. I thought she was a real person. For investigators, Luke DeWitt's complex and devious web of lies was, quote, phenomenal. It went beyond the online personas too. Luke didn't earn a computer science degree from the tertiary institution he claimed. He'd also told the Baxter's that he'd been diagnosed with bone marrow cancer. There were no records of this either. The extent of Luke's deceit wasn't just limited to the lies
德威特被捕，此时它们戛然而止。当她得知这些角色背后的真相时，艾莉崩溃了。“珍妮是一个值得信任的人，”她说。“我以为她是来帮忙的。我以为她是一个真实的人。”对于调查人员来说，卢克·德威特复杂而阴险的谎言网是“惊人的”。它也超出了在线角色的范围。卢克并没有获得他声称的那个高等教育机构的计算机科学学位。他还告诉巴克斯特夫妇他被诊断出患有骨髓癌。这些也没有记录。卢克欺骗的程度不仅限于
he'd told. A search of his home also turned up items of jewellery belonging to Car Carol Baxter that Luke had stolen from her. While Luke used his online personas to manipulate Carol, he'd been equally persistent in real life. He constantly pushed Carol to follow the doctor's rules, particularly when it came to drinking the health tonics they recommended. Over time, he convinced Stephen and Carol to drink whatever concoctions he made them until they no longer questioned it. Carol came to refer to Luke as her mixologist who made all of her potions. It was this behaviour that led investigators to conclude that Luke had been spiking Carol's health tonics for two years. This timing coincided with Carol's wellbeing taking a sharp and devastating turn for the worse. It wasn't Hashimoto's disease that was causing Carol's rapid mental and physical decline, but Promethazine. When taken in excess, Promethazine causes drowsiness, agitation,
他撒的谎。对他的家进行搜查还发现了属于卡罗尔·巴克斯特的珠宝，这些是卢克从她那里偷来的。虽然卢克利用他的在线角色来操纵卡罗尔，但他在现实生活中也同样执着。他不断推动卡罗尔遵守医生的规则，特别是在喝他们推荐的健康补品方面。随着时间的推移，他让史蒂芬和卡罗尔喝下他制作的任何混合物，直到他们不再质疑。卡罗尔开始称卢克为她的“调酒师”，他制作了她所有的药水。正是这种行为导致调查人员得出结论，卢克两年来一直在卡罗尔的健康补品中下毒。这个时间点与卡罗尔的健康状况急剧恶化相吻合。导致卡罗尔精神和身体迅速衰退的不是桥本氏病，而是异丙嗪。过量服用异丙嗪会导致嗜睡、烦躁、
nervousness, confusion, disorientation, depression, and delirium. A detective who worked on the case said, "...Carol's behaviour became erratic because we now know she was being poisoned on a regular basis. On one occasion, Luke inconspicuously fed Carol the capsule that contained the nail that was later uncovered in her colon. What Carol endured was described as nothing short of torture. CCTV footage taken from the Baxter's outdoor security camera confirmed that Luke had arrived at their house at 10.20am on Friday, April 7, 2023. Investigators believed this is when he dipped several of his late father's fentanyl patches into a so-called health tonic before serving it to Stephen and Carol. Luke then left but returned to the house at 4pm. He likely used this time to
紧张、困惑、迷失方向、抑郁和谵妄。一位参与此案的侦探说：“……卡罗尔的行为变得古怪，因为我们现在知道她一直在被定期下毒。”有一次，卢克不动声色地喂给卡罗尔胶囊，里面装有后来在她结肠中发现的钉子。卡罗尔所忍受的简直就是折磨。巴克斯特家户外监控摄像头的录像证实，卢克于2023年4月7日星期五上午10点20分到达他们家。调查人员认为，就在这时，他将他已故父亲的几片芬太尼贴片浸入所谓的健康补品中，然后端给史蒂芬和卡罗尔。卢克随后离开，但在下午4点回到房子。他很可能利用这段时间
check how the couple's overdose was progressing and to clean up the scene, including whatever he had served the fentanyl in. Shortly before leaving the premises that night, Luke transferred £6,000 from the Baxter's personal bank account to the business account he handled, which he labelled as loan. He also used Carol's phone to search for holidays to Disneyland. Later on, he researched how to delete footage from home security cameras. Police believed he was endeavouring to destroy the footage from the Baxter house to cover his tracks. Police also discovered that Luke had downloaded a home surveillance application on his phone that enabled him to watch a live video feed from the camera of another device. Images
检查这对夫妇的过量情况进展如何，并清理现场，包括他用什么盛放芬太尼。那天晚上离开现场前不久，卢克从巴克斯特夫妇的个人银行账户转了6000英镑到他经手的企业账户，他将其标记为“贷款”。他还用卡罗尔的手机搜索去迪士尼乐园的假期。后来，他研究了如何删除家庭监控摄像头的录像。警方认为他正试图销毁巴克斯特家的录像以掩盖罪行。警方还发现卢克在他的手机上下载了一个家庭监控应用程序，使他能够从另一个设备的摄像头观看实时视频流。图像
were recovered from Luke's phone that showed Stephen and Carol slumped in their armchairs in the conservatory. It appeared that he'd set up a camera in the conservatory and used the home surveillance application to watch the couple die on his phone in real time. This meant that as he'd gone about his errands and social events on Saturday April 8, he was spying on the Baxter's while they were dying. This added a sinister overtone to the dinner he had treated Ellie and Marcus to that night. The trio had socialised happily with nothing about Luke's behaviour indicating that anything was out of the ordinary. When the bodies of Carol and Stephen were discovered the next day, Luke played the convincing role of a shocked and concerned family friend. Even the police had no
从卢克的手机中恢复，显示史蒂芬和卡罗尔瘫倒在温室的扶手椅上。看来他在温室里安装了一个摄像头，并使用家庭监控应用程序在手机上实时观看这对夫妇死去。这意味着当他在4月8日星期六忙于跑腿和社交活动时，他正在监视垂死的巴克斯特夫妇。这给那天晚上他请艾莉和马库斯吃的晚餐增添了一种阴险的色彩。三人组愉快地社交，卢克的行为没有任何迹象表明有什么异常。当第二天发现卡罗尔和史蒂芬的尸体时，卢克扮演了一个令人信服的震惊和关心的家庭朋友的角色。甚至警方也没有
reason to doubt him. At one stage, Luke inconspicuously slipped the used fentanyl patches into Carol's medicine box, likely in an attempt to bolster the theory that the Baxter's deaths were the result of a murder-suicide. But at 6.54am the very next day, records showed he drafted the codicil on his phone, making himself the beneficiary and inheritor of Kaz Splash. He then left a copy of the document in Carole's home office. The codicil was supposedly crafted by a solicitor named Martin Ellison, but unsurprisingly, he was found to be yet another one of Luke's fake identities. When Luke DeWitt was arrested, he offered innocent excuses and explanations to the allegations levelled against him. He denied drugging and killing Stephen and Carol Baxter before receiving advice from a solicitor, after which he responded, no comment to all questions.
理由怀疑他。有一次，卢克不动声色地将用过的芬太尼贴片滑入卡罗尔的药盒中，很可能是为了支持巴克斯特夫妇的死亡是谋杀-自杀的结果这一理论。但就在第二天早上6点54分，记录显示他在手机上起草了遗嘱附录，使自己成为Kaz Splash的受益人和继承人。然后他把这份文件的副本留在了卡罗尔的家庭办公室。这份附录据称是由一位名叫马丁·埃里森的律师起草的，但不出所料，他被发现是卢克的又一个虚假身份。当卢克·德威特被捕时，他为针对他的指控提供了无辜的借口和解释。在接受律师建议之前，他否认给史蒂芬和卡罗尔·巴克斯特下药并杀害他们，之后他对所有问题都回答“无可奉告”。
Luke was ultimately charged with two counts of murder, possession of a Class A drug, and theft in relation to Carrol's jury. Luke DeWitt pleaded not guilty before his six-week trial commenced in mid-February 2024. The defence endeavoured to prove that Luke played no part in the Baxter's deaths and alluded to a cover-up. At one stage, they tried to implicate Ellie Baxter, explaining that she, too, stood to benefit financially from her parents' deaths. They referenced a statement provided by a neighbour of the Baxters who had reported hearing Carol and Stephen having a heated row with Ellie on the evening of Saturday, April 8. However, Carol's pacemaker had registered no activity that night, proving she was already dead at the time this alleged argument occurred.
卢克最终被控两项谋杀罪、持有A类毒品罪以及与卡罗尔珠宝有关的盗窃罪。卢克·德威特在2024年2月中旬为期六周的审判开始前拒不认罪。辩方试图证明卢克在巴克斯特夫妇的死亡中没有扮演任何角色，并暗示存在掩盖行为。有一次，他们试图牵连艾莉·巴克斯特，解释说她也从父母的死亡中获得了经济利益。他们引用了巴克斯特家一位邻居提供的陈述，该邻居报告说在4月8日星期六晚上听到卡罗尔和史蒂芬与艾莉发生了激烈的争吵。然而，卡罗尔的心脏起搏器在那天晚上没有记录到任何活动，证明她在这次所谓的争吵发生时已经死亡。
Ellie vehemently denied having any involvement in the murders, telling the court, doctors, telling the court, "'All I'm guilty of is loving my parents.'" Luke DeWitt took the stand in his own defence where he attempted to frame the deaths as a murder-suicide perpetrated by Stephen Baxter. He asserted that the health drinks he served to Stephen and Carol were harmless and did not contain any drugs or poisons. He also claimed that Dr Andrea Bowden and the other online personas were actually Stephen's idea. According to Luke, Stephen had instructed him to create the identities as a means of supporting
艾莉强烈否认参与了谋杀，告诉法庭：“我唯一有罪的就是爱我的父母。”卢克·德威特在自己的辩护中出庭，试图将死亡事件描述为史蒂芬·巴克斯特实施的谋杀-自杀。他断言他端给史蒂芬和卡罗尔的健康饮料是无害的，不含任何药物或毒药。他还声称安德里亚·鲍登医生和其他在线角色实际上是史蒂芬的主意。据卢克说，史蒂芬指示他创建这些身份，作为支持
Carol and to give her someone to talk to. The prosecution argued that at no point in the extensive communications Stephen had with the identities did he show any indication that he knew Luke was behind them. They asserted that Luke had murdered the Baxters calmly, coolly and in a way which had been entirely planned, maybe, for some while. The obvious motive was financial gain. Given that Luke had insider knowledge of Kaz Splash's finances, he knew the business had effectively ceased trading due to debt and had no means of repaying the 15,000 pounds he had loaned to foster its growth. The prosecution argued that Luke also received sadistic satisfaction from the infliction of pain and suffering. In the words of the prosecution, Luke fooled everyone he knew by
卡罗尔并给她一个倾诉对象的方式。控方辩称，在史蒂芬与这些身份进行的广泛交流中，他从未表现出任何迹象表明他知道卢克是幕后黑手。他们断言卢克冷静、从容地谋杀了巴克斯特夫妇，而且是完全计划好的，也许已经计划了一段时间。显而易见的动机是经济利益。鉴于卢克掌握Kaz Splash财务的内幕信息，他知道该公司因债务实际上已经停止交易，并且没有办法偿还他为促进其增长而借出的15000英镑。控方辩称，卢克还从施加痛苦和折磨中获得了施虐的快感。用控方的话说，卢克欺骗了他认识的每一个人，
portraying himself as an upstanding and kind member of the community when in reality he was one of the most dangerous men that police had ever come across. It was clear that Luke sought control, and deciding whether a person lives or dies is its ultimate form. As far as the case detectives were concerned, it was Luke's arrogance that led to his downfall. He didn't cover his tracks well and was deluded into thinking that fentanyl could be used to kill two people without arousing suspicion. While the defence had called several witnesses to attest to Luke's good nature, the prosecution told the jury, you may be tempted to be beguiled like others. There are legions of people that have fallen for his manipulation and
将自己描绘成社区中正直善良的一员，而实际上他是警方遇到过的最危险的人之一。很明显，卢克寻求控制，而决定一个人的生死是控制的终极形式。就案件侦探而言，是卢克的傲慢导致了他的垮台。他没有很好地掩盖自己的踪迹，并被误导认为芬太尼可以用来杀死两个人而不引起怀疑。虽然辩方传唤了几名证人来证明卢克的善良本性，但控方告诉陪审团：“你们可能会像其他人一样被诱惑。有无数人落入了他的操纵和
lies. After three days of deliberation, the jury unanimously found Luke DeWitt guilty of the murders of Stephen and Carol Baxter. Luke remained straight-faced when the verdict was read. In his sentencing remarks, the presiding judge called Luke's actions cruel and senseless. Quote, "...you ended Carol and Stephen Baxter's lives and you brought grief and misery to the lives of others, especially their children. You have given them years of pain and trauma. For the murders of Carol and Stephen Baxter, I impose on you concurrent sentences of life imprisonment, with a fixed term of 37 years." Luke DeWitt never offered any explanation as to why he turned against Stephen and Carol Baxter
谎言中。”经过三天的审议，陪审团一致裁定卢克·德威特谋杀史蒂芬和卡罗尔·巴克斯特罪名成立。宣读判决时，卢克面无表情。在量刑陈述中，主审法官称卢克的行为残忍且毫无意义。“你结束了卡罗尔和史蒂芬·巴克斯特的生命，给其他人的生活带来了悲伤和痛苦，尤其是他们的孩子。你给了他们多年的痛苦和创伤。对于谋杀卡罗尔和史蒂芬·巴克斯特，我判处你终身监禁，固定刑期为37年。”卢克·德威特从未解释过为什么他在
after years of friendship. He wasn't found to have suffered from any behaviour altering mental illnesses. Ellie Baxter said she sensed a change in Luke after the death of his father. A case detective concluded, Ultimately, the only person in this world who knows why he acted this way is Luke DeWitt, and he has proven time and time again to be a manipulator. What we do know is, the significant sentence handed down is entirely fitting for the pathological liar that he is. Given the way that Luke had been hoarding fentanyl patches, police believed he would've
多年的友谊后背叛了史蒂芬和卡罗尔·巴克斯特。他没有被发现患有任何改变行为的精神疾病。艾莉·巴克斯特说，她在卢克父亲去世后感觉到他发生了变化。一位案件侦探总结道：“最终，这个世界上唯一知道他为什么这样做的人是卢克·德威特，他一次又一次地证明自己是一个操纵者。我们所知道的是，所判处的重刑对于他这个病态的骗子来说是完全合适的。”鉴于卢克囤积芬太尼贴片的方式，警方认为他
gone on to kill again had he not been caught. They have since been looking into the possibility that Luke could've been involved in the deaths of his father and grandfather. According to Stephen and Carol's son, Harry, his family were simply do dolls in Luke DeWitt's dollhouse. Speaking of his mother's heart-wrenching decline, Harry said, "...I feel great sadness looking back on the videos of her when she was acting strangely and seeing Luke in the background giggling and smiling, knowing he's the one inflicting this pain. He completely destroyed everything we held close to our hearts and every memory and future dream we could have shared. In the months after her parents' deaths, Ellie Baxter gave birth to a healthy baby girl. Her parents' absence during this time was
如果没被抓住，他会继续杀人。他们此后一直在调查卢克可能参与他父亲和祖父死亡的可能性。据史蒂芬和卡罗尔的儿子哈里说，他的家人只是卢克·德威特玩偶屋里的玩偶。谈到他母亲令人心碎的衰退，哈里说：“回顾她行为怪异时的视频，看到卢克在背景中咯咯笑和微笑，知道是他造成了这种痛苦，我感到非常悲伤。他彻底摧毁了我们珍视的一切，以及我们本可以分享的每一个记忆和未来梦想。”在父母去世后的几个月里，艾莉·巴克斯特生下了一个健康的女儿。父母在这段时间的缺席是
particularly painful. Ellie later told the Daily Mail, "...they never got to meet their baby granddaughter. I'm still young and there are so many times when I just want my mum. It's one thing people passing, but for them to be taken like that, there are no words really." My parents had worked hard all their lives and saved up and they were really looking forward to retiring, and that got taken away by someone that they cared for and trusted like a son. Ellie has since reflected on her time with Luke DeWitt and recalls instances during her pregnancy when he offered her energy drinks. Although Ellie only ever took a sip, the drinks gave her an adverse reaction and she became overly drowsy. Her health improved
特别痛苦的。艾莉后来告诉《每日邮报》：“他们从未见过他们的孙女。我还很年轻，有很多时候我只是想要我的妈妈。人们去世是一回事，但以那种方式被带走，真的无法用言语形容。”我的父母一生努力工作，存钱，他们真的很期待退休，但那被一个他们像儿子一样关心和信任的人夺走了。艾莉此后反思了她与卢克·德威特在一起的时光，并回忆起怀孕期间他给她提供能量饮料的例子。虽然艾莉只喝了一口，但这些饮料让她产生了不良反应，她变得过度嗜睡。她的健康状况有所改善
whenever she took a break from seeing Luke and her issues disappeared entirely once he was arrested. Ellie has been left with the chilling realisation that Luke might have been poisoning her too. In 2011, a tragedy unfolded along the banks of a quiet suburban creek in Melbourne, Australia. Emergency services. Hello, where do you need the police? I think I've seen what looks like a dead body in... Where? In the creek was the body of a young adult female, clad in a pink dressing gown. He assumed that she just threw her robe off
每当她休息不去看卢克时，她的问题在他被捕后完全消失了。艾莉留下了一个令人不寒而栗的认识，即卢克可能也在给她下毒。2011年，一场悲剧在澳大利亚墨尔本一条安静的郊区小溪边上演。紧急服务。你好，你需要警察吗？我想我看到了看起来像一具尸体的东西在……在哪里？在小溪里是一具年轻成年女性的尸体，穿着粉红色的睡袍。他以为她只是把长袍扔掉
and just threw it in the water. But little did he know that that was actually a lifeless body. Police were quick to rule out any suspicious circumstances, while others weren't so sure. Lois was a very, very good swimmer. We'd gone to the beach, we'd gone to the pools. You cannot just look at a body and say, oh, they drowned or no, they didn't drown.
然后把它扔进了水里。但他不知道那实际上是一具冰冷的尸体。警方很快排除了任何可疑情况，而其他人则不那么确定。“洛伊斯是一个非常非常好的游泳者。我们去过海滩，去过游泳池。你不能只看一具尸体就说，哦，他们淹死了，或者不，他们没有淹死。”
It's based on the circumstances. Her death is a case you've never heard of before, but her life is a story you'll never forget. I kept the time on my list of my, be careful going there, because one day, you know, you might decide to not want to come back. Or for living conditions,
这是基于具体情况。她的死是你从未听说过的案件，但她的一生是你永远不会忘记的故事。我把时间记在我的名单上，小心去那里，因为有一天，你知道，你可能会决定不想回来。或者为了生活条件，
and he would just give her food like she was a prisoner. They were big tough guys though, they looked really mean, but they wanted to help her. As a fresh investigation into her death begins, startling revelations come to light. I collected a female from the Melbourne airport. She was upset and crying. Looking at her lungs right now.
他会给她食物，就像她是囚犯一样。他们是大块头硬汉，看起来很刻薄，但他们想帮助她。随着对她死亡的新调查开始，惊人的启示浮出水面。“我从墨尔本机场接了一名女性。她很沮丧，在哭。现在看看她的肺。”
And her lungs? Aha! Never once in my life have I ever rang anyone and offered them drugs. Is that ridiculous? It is like to say that this case is consistent with drowning. This is not love or kindness or respect. We've got you. I'm Julia Robson and this is Troubled Waters.
“还有她的肺？啊哈！我这辈子从来没有给任何人打过电话并给他们提供毒品。这荒谬吗？这就像说这个案件与溺水一致。这不是爱，也不是善良或尊重。我们抓住你了。我是朱莉娅·罗布森，这是《麻烦水域》。”
A Case File Presents production. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Case File Presents制作。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子发表评论。